all right let's go to a voicemail 2192
david p is the voicemail number quick
reminder the new website is up and
running brand-new david pakman.com if
you want a fifty percent discount on
your membership to help us test the new
membership system the coupon code is
beta 50b ETA 50 it is a fifty percent
discount only for the first 25 ppl after
25 people use that code the coupon
expires check it out let's go now to
voicemail last week we had this
voicemail louis from ramon Ramos who was
clearly just Troy York using a different
name in a slightly altered voice Troy
York I left a voicemail saying that
wasn't him but he happens to really
agree with Ramon Ramos take a listen to
this embankment destroy York and you
have a show about how trans Nationals I
like yourself are abusing using the
economy that's why you have all these
high-end restaurants in urban
neighborhoods and all the rural areas
have gas stations and akon marks by
dollar stores and uh I heard you message
that was not me I don't know who Raymond
Ramos is but there was not me a call the
other day ah but I agree with everything
he says pray ah that there is conspiracy
they only are Americans live in rural
and small-town Main Street and the Wall
Street da Hollywood are connections by
these transnational is from Argentina
and Europe and the Middle East who come
and open all these restaurants and put
this economy the shame using to
government to outsource other okay yeah
let's stop it there so okay but Ramon
Ramos and Troy York share the same voice
it wasn't the same person but by the way
both have what is not a widely held view
that there is a conspiracy to put the
nice restaurants in urban areas and gas
stations in rural areas which of course
makes perfect sense you but the
restaurants were there are lots of
people you put the gas stations where
you need cars to get around amazing
Louis that someone with the exact same
voice called in and had these very very
unique and sort of niche concerns uh
very very coincidental isn't it maybe
they were separated at Birth brothers
just a theory on the bonus show today
we will tell you about the entire
Russian Paralympic team being banned
okay did the entire team has been banned
also another instance of significant
paranoia on american airline flights and
a noodle stall has received a Michelin
star I saw an interesting little
documentary about this we will talk
about all of those stories and more
david pakman.com slash membership to
sign up instantly on the brand-new david
pakman.com website and of course beta 50
b ETA 50 for the first 25 people who
type in that coupon code on the new
website you will get a fifty percent
discount on your membership